ZONE INSIDE OF THAT CITY.
WE WILL SHOW YOU HOW THAT’S
WORKING OUT TONIGHT FOR THEM.
WE TURNED TO THE PRESUMPTIVE
NOMINEE AND IT, THAT MADE THE
SECURITY OF HIS BASEMENT BUNKER
AND HE TWEETED "NOTHING ABOUT
THE FIGHTS WILL BE EASY.
I’M READY TO GET TO WORK ON DAY
NUMBER ONE.
THE EVER FORGETFUL JOE MUST BE
CONFUSED YET AGAIN, BECAUSE HIS
DAY ONE WAS ACTUALLY OVER 40
YEARS AGO.
NOW HE HAS A TRACK RECORD THAT
DOES NOT MATCH HIS RHETORIC.
WHAT DID BIDEN DO TO END RACISM
DURING HIS SIX TERMS IN THE U.S.
SENATE?
HIS TWO TERMS IN THE AS
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IT BEGAN IN 1973 DURING THE
SPEECH, AND THEY ARE WORKING
WITH DESEGREGATION.
HE OPPOSED SCHOOL BUSING,
ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS, HE LED
THE CHARGE ON THAT ISSUE THAT
KEPT BLACK STUDENTS AWAY FROM
THE CLASSROOMS OF WHITE
STUDENTS.
AND, HE COAUTHORED A VERY
AGGRESSIVE CRIME BILL.
THAT RAMPED UP PRISON SENTENCES
FOR DOZENS OF CRIMES.
WE HAVE THE VIDEO EVIDENCE AND
VIDEOTAPE.
>> I WANT TO KNOCK MY WIFE WAS A
LEAD PIPE, TAKE ON MY SONS.
SO I WANT TO ASK, WHAT MADE THEM
DO THIS?
THEY MUST BE TAKEN OFF THE
STREETS.
WE SHOULD FOCUS ON THEM NOW.
NOT OUT OF A LIBERAL INSTINCT
FOR LOVE, AND HUMANITY, AND FOR
SIMPLE PRAGMATIC REASONS.
IF WE DON’T, THEY WILL.
OR A PORTION OF THEM WILL COME
THE PREDATORS 15 YEARS FROM NOW.
MADAM PRESIDENT, WE HAVE
PREDATORS ON OUR STREETS.
>> Sean: WHEN THE CRIME BILL
BECAME LAW, BIDEN WAS SO PROUD
OF HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT HE
BRAGGED, AND THIS IS THE SAME
GUY THAT PRETENDED TO BE A CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADER FOR YEARS.
AND HE LIED ABOUT MARCHING IN
THE CIVIL RIGHTS PROTEST.
RECENTLY HE’D LIED ABOUT GETTING
ARRESTED BY THE APARTHEID IN
SOUTH AFRICA GOVERNMENT WHILE ON
HIS WAY TO SEE NELSON MANDELA.
A FEW WEEKS AGO HE LIED ABOUT
HIS MANY POLITICAL ENDORSEMENTS
FROM THE NAACP.
THEY DON’T ENDORSE, THEY NEVER
ENDORSED HIM.
BY THE WAY, WHAT DID HE DO TO
FIX SYSTEMIC RACISM?
OKAY, IT WAS UNDER BARACK AND
JOE’S WATCH.
AND WHAT DID HE DO TO FIX THE
SYSTEMATIC RACISM, THE 70s,
THE 80s, THE 90s AND
2000s.
YOU SOUND LIKE A MAN, WHO IS
PARTICULARLY WORRIED ABOUT
RACISM.
>> IT’S THE LARGEST GROWTH IN
POPULATION IS INDIAN-AMERICAN.
YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7-ELEVEN OR A
DUNKIN’ DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE A
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
>> WHAT KIND OF A CHANCE WHAT A
NORTHEASTERN LIBERAL STAND IN
THE SOUTH.
MY STATE IS THE EIGHTH LARGEST
BLACK POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY.
>> >> WE CAN KEEP GOING.
FIRST, MAINSTREAM
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, THE FIRST ONE
AND THIS IS A STORY BOOK.
A FEW WEEKS AGO BIDEN TOLD RADIO
HOST CHARLEMAGNE, THE FOLLOWING.
>> WE HAVE MORE QUESTIONS.
>> IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM, THEN
YOU AIN’T BLACK.
>> Sean: IT’S PRETTY OBVIOUS
WHY BIDEN SPENDS MOST OF HIS
DAYS HIDING IN HIS BASEMENT AND
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN CAUGHT ON
TAPE, THEY DON’T ANYONE TO SEE
THE REAL JOE BIDEN.
THE RACIAL RHETORIC, CONSTANT
CONFUSION, QUESTIONS AND AMERICA
WILL HAVE TO ASK AND ANSWER IN
146 DAYS.
AND DOES HE HAVE THE MENTAL
ALERTNESS, THE STAMINA, TO TAKE
ON WHAT IS THE HARDEST JOB IN
THE WORLD, IS HE UP FOR THE JOB?
WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN HE
FINALLY HAS TO LEAVE HIS
BASEMENT BUNKER?
AND THAT’S AS LONG AS POSSIBLE
OUT OF THE SPOTLIGHT, KEEP HIM
IN THE BASEMENT AND KEEP HIM
THERE.
HE DOES A COUPLE OF CALLS A DAY,
HE’S GOING TO.
>> TWO PEOPLE SEE THEM A DAY,
AND MUST BE THERE’S A WHOLE NEW
STRATEGY FOR WINNING THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT, HIDE IN THE
BASEMENT.
THEY ARE SCARED TO DEATH AS SOON
AS HE OPENS HIS MOUTH.
AND RIGHTFULLY SO.
BIDEN WILL HAVE TO KEEP TRACK OF
DECADES OF EVER EVOLVING LIES,
POLITICAL POSTURING, AND IF
DONALD TRUMP HAD HIS HISTORY YOU
WOULD THINK THE MAIN STREAM
MEDIA MOB WOULD GIVE HIM A PASS
OR COME UP WITH A BE ASKING HIM
QUESTIONS ALL THE TIME?
FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW HE’S ONCE
AGAIN PRETENDING TO BE ON THE
FOREFRONT OF EQUALITY.
HE SAID HE WANTS TO "URGENTLY
ROOT OUT SYSTEMIC RACISM TO
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AND IN HIS
RECENT OP-ED, I WONDER WHO WROTE
IT?
PAINTED AMERICA’S POLICE WITH A
BROAD BRUSH CALLING HIM
SYSTEMATICALLY RACIST, THE ONES
HE WAS BRAGGING ABOUT HIRING AS
HE WAS BRAGGING ABOUT THE CRIME
BILL AND ALL THE PREDATORS ON
THE STREET.
AND IN DOING SO HE’S TURNING ON
THE VERY POLICE THAT HE ONCE
CLAIMED TO SUPPORT.
IF THAT’S THE CASE, IS JOE THE
FORGETFUL ONE GOING TO SAY ALL
OF THAT?
HE HAS ARM SECURITY AND
SECRET SERVICE AGENTS AT RISK
THEIR LIFE DAILY TO KEEP HIM
ALIVE.
AND RIGHTLY SO IN MY MIND.
IS HE GOING TO SAY THAT TO THEM?
NOW WE HAVE SET ON THE SHOW,
THERE ARE BAD APPLES.
THEY SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES,
THEY SERVED WITH HONOR AND
DISTINCTION.
THEY PROTECT AND THEY SERVE.
BIDEN IS DISRESPECTING THE
DECENT MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES DAY IN
AND DAY OUT, THE GOOD COPS,
PROTECTING AND SERVING.
SERVING YOUR COMMUNITY IS AND
HE’S DISRESPECTING THOSE WHO
HAVE FALLEN IN THE LINE OF DUTY
INCLUDING THOSE WHO BRAVELY
RUSHED INTO THE BURNING
BUILDINGS IN NEW YORK.
REMEMBER?
EVERYONE IS TRYING TO ESCAPE,
THIS WHOLE GROUP OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
FIREMEN, PARAMEDICS, PLACEMENT
ON THEIR WAY UP TO SAVE LIVES.
SEVERAL HAVE BEEN INJURED IN
LAST WEEK’S RIOTS.
THAT’S THE LIVES OF OVER 20
PEOPLE AND NBC, 22 POLICE
OFFICERS WERE HOSPITALIZED AFTER
GETTING PELTED WITH, LET’S SEE,
BRICKS, ROCKS AND BOTTLES,
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS AIMED AT THEIR
HEADS.
OTHERS WERE CHARGED WITH NAMING
THE LASER AT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AIRCRAFT.
ONE LAS VEGAS POLICE OFFICERS
SHOT IN THE HEAD LAST WEEK.
HE MIGHT NEED IT NOW AND A
VENTILATOR FOR THE REST OF HIS
LIFE.
AND WE MUST NEVER FORGET, A
RETIRED ST. LOUIS POLICE CAPTAIN
DAVID DORN, 38 YEARS HE SERVED
THIS COMMUNITY WITH HONOR AND
DISTINCTION.
HE WAS MURDERED TRYING TO
PROTECT A LOCAL STORE FOR MOVERS
MOVERS.
I ALWAYS SAY THAT 99%, THEY ARE
HEROES.
BIDEN IS NOW USING THEM AS MERE
POLITICAL PAWNS.
WHEN IT SERVES AS INTEREST, THEY